Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number, which
is 2192. David P you know, I mentioned that
it's interesting that when all of those MAGA
people came into the city, into New York City,
sorry for Trump's arrest a few weeks ago,
despite all of them claiming all the time New
York City is so dangerous, it's dangerous. It's
crazy. In New York City. We didn't hear about
any of those people that came into the city for
Trump's arrest, even witnessing a single crime,
never mind being victimized by it. Here's
a caller who says he did see a crime when
he was in New York City. Listen to this.
Speaker 5: David, I heard you saying how.
You haven't really witnessed crime in New
York City, and I think you're being a little
disingenuous. For example, a few weeks
ago, I was in New York with some friends,
and we witnessed a man in broad daylight being
held up and robbed right across the street. And we
marveled at it. And then what's really shocking
is we were all arrested for breaking the Good
Samaritan law because we didn't help him. Have you
ever heard of anything like this before? Yes, I.
Speaker 1: Have. This is a Seinfeld episode.
Speaker 5: Sounds crazy to me. My lawyer said it
was preposterous, ludicrous, outrageous. I'm still
waiting to, you know, to get bailed out here, so.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So that's I'm sure that was
Attorney Jackie Chiles who said that. No,
listen, I mean, all over New York City. Not
really Staten Island. I've only been there
once. I just took the ferry, got off and got
right back on. But Manhattan, Brooklyn, Queens
and the Bronx, where I've been to some
Yankees games when the Sox are in town,
I have never witnessed a single crime. Now, have
I seen mental illness that sometimes becomes
aggressive? I have. Yeah, that's true. Have I seen
bodily fluids on the subway? Yes, I have. But when
we're talking about, you know, the sort of rampant
criminality that the right loves to say is just
everywhere in New York City, I've never seen it.
Do I know? I mean, I guess I know. I know probably